well it looks like we are starting to
learn more and more about Marvel
studios's plans for the Fantastic 4 and
the X-Men in the MCU the two major
franchises that are going to push
forward the MCU Post Secret Wars we are
learning more about them not only what
they're going to do with them before
secret wars during Secret Wars but also
after Secret Wars as well and as we
learn a little bit more about the
Fantastic 4 and the X-Men we learn a
little bit more overall what Marvel
studios's plans are for Secret Wars but
also Post Secret Wars and it sounds like
it's all really about to go down in
Deadpool 3 and the Fantastic 4 with some
really interesting plots coming into
both these movies and the MCU overall
and some people might not like what
Marvel Studios has planned for the X-Men
but some people might love it you'll
have to let us know what you think about
it in the comments at the end of this
video but from what we're hearing it
sounds like the reboot of the new X-Men
that are going to appear in the MCU Post
Secret Wars isn't 100% going to be
really a full reboot and of course we'll
break down what this means and talk
about how Marvel Studios could actually
execute this and don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment down below
to enter our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month so
when it comes to the new X-Men we're not
talking about the X-Men that are going
to be reintroduced to us in Deadpool 3
in secret Wars and anything else that we
might see them in leading up to Secret
Wars no spoilers for anything that has
happened recently in Marvel studios's
world but we have seen one of them
return already if youve seen it then of
course you know if not you'll hear about
it soon pretty sure everybody knows what
I'm talking about but I won't spoil it
for those who haven't seen it but we've
been talking for a while about how these
original Fox X-Men characters are going
to be appearing in the MCU this is
widely known now and even Marvel Studios
has has made that clear in fact in the
marketing for the Marvels they have
already teased the X-Men but of course
fans want to know about the new Xmen the
new X-Men characters the New Mutants
who's coming to the MCU maybe before
Secret Wars but what is it going to look
like after Secret Wars and according to
this recent report we are going to get
some new X-Men but it looks like some of
these older X-Men characters and their
actors who play them are going to be
sticking around Post Secret Wars which
is really interesting however it does
kind of makes sense story-wise if they
want to keep the continuity of the MCU
going let me explain the new report says
that the MCU X-Men will be introduced
after Secret Wars and will come from
Another Universe and some old Fox X-Men
actors might stick around now this
report is coming from Grace Randolph she
reported this in one of her recent
videos and this is kind of what we
thought was going to happen a bit ago
before they really started talking about
the reboot of the MCU well as we've
gotten further along and we've learned
more about Marvel Studios over the past
couple of months we've learned that the
soft reboot is very real and is most
likely what we are going to be
experiencing Post Secret Wars basically
what this means is not everything is
going to be erased from our universe and
all of the universes the Multiverse at
the end of Secret Wars but some things
are going to remain from what we know
they're going to have a shared Universe
after as the main MCU where characters
from other universes whose universes got
destroyed and they can't go back are
going to remain in our universe I think
the overall idea of this is to where we
can have kind of a fresh start but
you're not erasing everything that
happened in the 616 Universe from Iron
Man to now because that sort of would be
a slap in the face to us you're going to
start a new universe and say that Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man never existed Chris
evans's Captain America Scarlett
Johansson's Black Widow Avengers
Infinity War an endgame never happened
we all love those characters and those
moments and we love that they are
connected to the universe that we are
still following so to completely wipe
them from existence would suck so rather
than completely start over we're simply
going to be fusing a lot of different
universes into one and not everything
from our universe is going to make it so
we might actually be one of those
universes that gets partially or fully
destroyed but before that happens a part
of our universe including Heroes and the
civilians from every planet out there in
our universe could bleed over into
whatever Universe we fuse with but it
does sound like our universe is going to
be destroyed but we're going to have
some survivors from it end up in another
Universe along with remnants of a bunch
of different universes as well we'll
essentially have a Melting Pot of Heroes
but like I mentioned as well other
populations the civilians of earths and
aliens from other planets but this does
kind of answer the question of well how
come we haven't heard of mutants or any
X-Men at any point in time well perhaps
they didn't really exist in our universe
now they have been kind of prepping us
for it they did did say that Miss Marvel
was a mutant but what we've heard
recently is that Marvel Studios is going
to basically take this soft reboot as an
opportunity to prune pun intended
anything that's really not working for
them side note I do think Miss Marvel is
going to stick around that's not a
direct shot at her character saying
she's going to be pruned or anything but
my point is things can basically change
to whatever Marvel Studios wants them to
change to and it's an interesting
concept keeping some of the older X-Men
characters while bringing in some new
ones and since the populations are going
to be merged we are going to eventually
have people who are born with mutant
Powers naturally from this new universe
that's going to be created and of course
over time those older X-Men characters
will die off in the MCU so ultimately
there will be a time where none of those
original actors are around anymore and
it's simply just new X-Men in the MCU it
is also worth noting that we have heard
that the Fantastic 4 might be set in a
different universe and yes I am talking
about the new reboot movie that that is
supposed to be coming relatively soon
still waiting on that casting
announcement from them but this was also
coming from Grace Randolph and she said
that Marvel studios's plans is for them
to set the Fantastic Four in the 1960s
and have them exist in Another Universe
Another Universe where they are the only
superheroes around they are literally
the only superheroes in their universe
so they are very very famous they try to
stop Galactus but they fail and right
before the universe is about to be
destroyed due to an incursion or galatis
the TVA shows up and saves them and this
is reportedly what we're supposed to see
in Deadpool 3 the TVA will be involved
in fact the TVA is going to have
Deadpool prisoner because of what he did
at the end of Deadpool 2 he started
messing around with time so in Deadpool
3 he's prisoner he escapes he travels
the Multiverse with hu Jackman he sees a
lot of stuff and one of the things that
he sees is the TVA now saving people
from universes that are about to die due
to incursions and they are taking all of
these survivors and putting them on one
universe and this one Universe might be
the universe that we are going to have
as the main Universe moving forward so
anybody he brings anybody from the old
Fox universe or any other type of
variant that we might see could be
sticking around if they survive Secret
Wars now Loki just sacrificed himself to
essentially have the Multiverse exists
so we assume that a Multiverse will
exist after Secret Wars and we actually
have just learned yesterday that Marvel
Studios has withdrawn trademarks for
Timeless Saga eternity Saga Nomad
runaways new ER but they did not
withdraw the trademark for Avengers
eternity Wars now eternity Wars does
kind of imply that the Multiverse will
still be around but for eternity Wars
time would play a bigger part which is
weird to say after we just watched Loki
season 2 but clearly Marvel Studios has
plans again not just for before Secret
Wars but after as well and it looks like
the X-Men along with the Avengers and
the Fantastic 4 might be coming together
for an Avengers film called eternity
wars in the future so so we'll have some
new X-Men but we'll also have some older
X-Men sticking around in the MCU what do
you think about that do you think it's
fine do you like this idea or would you
rather have the X-Men be new completely
new all new characters no remaining new
characters basically a full on hard
reboot let us know what you think in the
comments down below what would you
prefer don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest MCU news you can find
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof